before Bitcoin you would have bought
bars of soap crates of toilet paper you
would have bought motorcycles you would
have bought a Humvee you would have
bought barrels of oil you would have
bought anything you would bought food
you would have bought bullets you would
have bought guns anything tangible that
you can self-custody you would have held
now after Bitcoin you now have for the
first time in human history the ability
to buy not a barrel of oil but 80 worth
of bitcoin
and you put it on your phone
and now you can go through an airport
with the Bitcoin you can't go to there
through the airport with a barrel of oil